[Music]
what's up Hamilton Puerto Rico see Jack
here I love y'all Lin 9 so we call me 9
lots of words remember you wrote them
all that's original Hamilton past member
Christopher Jackson who played George
Washington showing his support for the
show's Puerto Rico run Manuel Miranda
will step back into his famous leading
role tonight but before that we have a
very special surprise for him let's go
back to David beg know who is in Dorado
beach Puerto Rico with the Hamilton star
David thanks John you know Lynn is
addicted to Twitter oh boy so much so
your wife told me yesterday she used to
change your password on the weekends yes
yeah so if you look at his Twitter his
bio says former substitute teacher and I
know teachers mean a lot to you so we
went to visit one who wanted to say
something but so Lynn this is your old
English teacher
dr. Herbert here I'm sure you didn't
imagine when you were in the eighth
grade and said some of the chosen to
music that it would lead you where you
are today but congratulations I've heard
a lot about what you're doing in Puerto
Rico and I wish you well in those
endeavors and continued great success
down there
very good I heard one of the first
people to say your work is worthy and we
pick you yeah dr. Herbert's the reason
I'm sitting here talking to you he was
the I was writing I wrote a musical
instead of doing my homework for his
class in eighth grade he said you could
be good at this and you should stop
hibernating in my class and you should
be doing this because we had a student
written Computer Club at my high school
and and remember it's the one who nudged
to me in that direction and he sort of
changed my life forever with that woman
all the way down to South Carolina to
find him speaking on the Twitter of you
by the way guys so Lynn has been
practicing his lines and he does it in
the laundry mat right in the
you know laundry room he still does his
own laundry and rides the bus and subway
by the way and there's a great video of
you practicing and you just totally flub
a lot oh yeah no there was a lot of that
because I and I have a different problem
than the other actors we're learning the
show which is I have all of the versions
of Hamilton in my show I have the cut
tunes I have guys did y'all see that one
yeah it's important to do laundry during
off-peak hours
Touche because otherwise everyone will
see you rehearsing
I don't know Lynn Lynn I love the letter
from dr. Herbert that said it's a
well-crafted essay confirms what I've
suspected for some time you've been
hibernating in the back of the class
come to the front and join us it's
almost spring it's amazing what a
teacher can do to transform your life we
were so glad that he wanted to talk to
you and that it clearly means something
that means the world to me yeah you've
transformed so many lives yourself thank
you so much David Beck now lin-manuel
Miranda and Puerto Rico good luck
tonight
ricky'll oh yes